[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
بعد ايام ستنتهي سنه الميلاديه 20 22
بحلوها ومرها فعداد السنين يزيد واعمارنا
تنقص وحساب السنين والشهور والايام وحتى
الفصول تبنى على حركه الاجرام السماويه
الشمس والقمر وكذلك النجوم فالانسان
القديم لاحظ ان الشمس تشرق وتمشي وتغيب
واذا غابت طلعت نجوم واذا طلعت نجوم غابت
الشمس ولا لحظه ان الشمس تعود سيرتها
الاولى كما بدات في فتره زمنيه محدده هذه
الفتره اقسمها الى اجزاء وهذه الاجزاء
اسماءها بالساعات فكل 24 ساعه يوم وكل 30
يوم يعود الهلال الوليد من جديد فاسمه
والشهر لشهرته وكل 12 شهر يبدا الولد
الجديد اللي هو المولود الجديد يطيح
اسنانه
لها امد وللامد انقضائه فبعد عتمه الظلماء
نور وطول الليل يعقبه
الضياء
[تصفيق]
ومع تطور الانسان وحاجته الماسه الى تنظيم
المواقيته الزراعيه والدينيه والاستماعيه
اضطر الى تنظيم وضبط ايامه المبعثره داخل
دفه التقويم والذي يعني التعديل والضبط
التقويم الميلادي يعتمد على الشمس
والتقويم الهجري يعتمد على القمر والتقويم
الصيني زاوج بين الشمس والقمر جاء الحبيب
الذي هواه من سفر والشمس قد اثرت في خده
اثر اعجبته كيف تحل الشمس في قمر والشمس
لا ينبغي لها ان تدرك القمره
[موسيقى]